the Joe Rogan experience who's singing
that version of Bonnie Raitt Bonnie
Raitt last yeah named after my mother
oh man is another town is growing old
dreams are thunder and I need was desire
you this old house would have burned
down a long time ago make me into the
flies from Montgomery make me a poster
of it all rodeo
just give me one thing leaving this
living hard way to go right job Prime
you'll have to work that out in a fuller
version this is more to it you want to
keep going well you want to play big man
okay keep playing it this is so good
okay all right I love big man to that I
want to hear that nice all right when I
was a young girl and I have me a cowboy
he wasn't much to look at just a free
round the man
that was a long time no matter how I
tried those years just flown by like a
broken-down me
brainy angel the fires from
maybe a poster
[Music]
just give me one thing I can hold on to
to believe in this living it's just a
hard way to go my jacket leaving this a
living is a hard way to go that was
beautiful
[Applause]